[Music]
national weather service doppler radar
is tracking a tornado on the ground
if possible please seek shelter in a
basement immediately
and make sure to avoid windows
holy cow
we are about to get slammed
the tornado is approaching us from the
southeast right now
we've got rain going all the way around
us
concealing any view of the tornado
we're starting to get closer to sunset
so not only are these tornadoes wrapped
in rain but they're hitting at night
and that's a dangerous situation
it could come at us out of the rain
whoa
there it is
we're whipping around
it is coming back toward the road
you've got the circulation right on top
of us
you're inside a tornado i believe
getting hit by debris
we're getting rocked
we're about to roll the van guys
[Music]
what do you think reid
that's taking off and growing
everything seems to be feeding into that
direction
it's really coming in fast now yeah
our storm is starting to intensify
big time winds coming in and it's these
winds that bring that moisture northward
from the gulf of mexico that make these
intense storms possible
i scale one to ten what does your gut
tell you that we're gonna see a tornado
out of this setup seven a seven seven
point five whew
all right
increasing though increasing by the
minute
there's a chance there could be the
biggest tornado of the year
we gotta hook this probe up marine all
right
i think we'll be able to get this into a
tornado today
data logger set up now we just got to
get in the path and deploy it
all right ready
by dropping this probe directly in the
path of the storm we can get highly
accurate data that few others can
each bit of data we get can help the
scientific community further understand
these ever-changing weather patterns
all right all right we gotta get serious
now
you ready yeah i'm ready let's go
yes
i just love storm chasing
i've been storm chasing non-stop since i
got my driver's license at age 16.
and my life is completely dedicated to
it
i don't have a wife i have no kids we
are about to intercept a tornado
i only own a couple of pairs of
underwear
all i do is storm chase and the peak of
the eyewall here wins gusting over 140
miles an hour now
i absolutely have a love affair with
extreme weather and storms and
there's nothing i'd rather do with my
life than trying to better understand
this weather
mother nature and her most extreme
[Music]
all right mike you want to head us a
little bit north yeah let's go
here we go time to buckle down
hold on
is that your pre-game warm-up a little
energy release that's all
this hurricane coming in the gulf
that looks big taking up the whole gulf
of mexico there
oh that's unbelievable
this early in the season
early june
1 in 50-year storm right there
hurricane season is starting to invade
tornado season and vice versa
and it's going to be dangerous
with all that warm air and moisture
pushing into the country for the
hurricane
i think this thing is going to produce
dozens of tornadoes
let's see if we can get used to this
stuff
oh
yeah
did they hit it
mike tyson and i have been friends for
over 20 years now
he's one of the most well-known
hurricane chasers on the planet they're
getting bigger by the minute
mike's chased in some of the most
dangerous areas around the globe we're
gonna have to retreat
we make a great team
[Applause]
we watch each other's back
but my favorite thing about mike
the guy has got a perfect head of
hair here we go we're coming through it
look out to the right
damn look at that thing
man this is wild
big time shelf cloud approaching us and
we think that that line of storms is
going to go nuclear you can see the
tornado risk area that we're right in
the middle of
there it comes coming in fast
wow
i've never seen anything like this
this is a very rare duration storm
the radicals are fast-moving bands of
thunderstorms that can produce
hurricane-force winds heavy rains and
even tornadoes
the tornado warning just came in
and it says winds could easily gust up
to 90 miles an hour with this and this
thing is racing toward us at about 70 or
80 miles an hour
so it's a fast-moving line as severe as
severe storms get
all right try to get the bird in the air
let's get it done
coming in quick yep
you see both sides of it now
perfect edge
wow
got this approaching shelf cloud coming
right at us multiple thunderstorms
embedded put the drone up
oh yeah
the drone is an incredibly valuable tool
for assessing storm structure
so when the storm's approaching we get
the drone into the air trying to find
exactly where the tornado is going to
touch down
that is beautiful
it's getting better by the minute
oh my god this is incredible
you can see it bowing out right in front
of us oh yeah
look we got hunks right above us
those birds are riding a thermal that
warm inflow
[Music]
this thing is surging out the birds
about to get overtaken by 90
mile-an-hour winds and look at that
that's the kink in the line that's where
the tornado would happen
and we've got the perfect road to
intercept it
we got to get to that mike let's get
ready to deploy
all right let's go
i gotta bring the drone down
bring it down bring it down where is it
i can't get it back
probably get blasted
we're trying to get the drone back but
the wind just took it away
do you see it
there it is
it's fighting it it's coming back
we got the drone back
look ground circulation
look at the dirt dirt on the ground
underneath it that's dirt
possible tornado out
here
there
ground circulation
possible tornado up there
let's go guys all right let's go
all right let's blast
hold on tight
fast as you can
you go a little faster
it's moving at like 70 miles an hour
there's just no road options and it's
moving too fast
we've lost it
tornadoes are the hardest type of storm
we chase
for every 20 tornadoes we might get one
intercept and those are not good odds
you just have to keep grinding to get
the data
i love it it was a beautiful experience
you know i'm glad that we got to share
that together but
we're out here to get this probe into a
tornado
mike and i have storm chased thousands
of miles
we are chasing year round now and that's
because given a warming climate these
forecasts are like things we've never
seen
sea surface temperatures are warming
across the globe
you're seeing powerful destructive
storms
which are difficult to predict
things are changing so quickly that's
why we need to chase every storm
possible and learn all we can
the remains of tropical storm crystal
ball are dumping heavy rains this
morning on the gulf coast
the storm made landfall south of new
orleans hitting hard in coastal
communities like waveland mississippi
and it is now moving up the mississippi
river valley bringing a chance of
tornadoes
[Music]
[Music]
as the long night
every night's a long night in the van
and there's nothing i'd rather do during
storm season than
sleep in a van with another man
[Music]
it's like mike's already up and at him
probably going to grab that foundation
breakfast that he needs every day looks
like a hipster brew here that mike got
going
[Music]
the grind of being on the road is
definitely legitimate
not a lot of sleep we eat a lot of gas
station food you drink a lot of caffeine
to stay sharp
that's good
it's rough but these storms aren't going
to chase themselves we've got to advance
our science mission no matter what and
this is it this is our home here
there he is
breakfast
here that's yours
ooh that's nice whoa
i try to eat four eggs every day you
can't run a ferrari engine without oil
so this is kind of the oil that i'm
adding to my engine
you got lucky charms are you kidding me
need a little luck need a little power
if you want some no thanks
today is the highest tornado potential
i've seen this season
we've got all the ingredients in place
for tornado producing storms as
cristobal's finally lifting north
if we don't get our probe into a tornado
today then there's definitely something
wrong with us
let's watch it for a bit right here
wow
that looks good
this is the storm we want
there's a chance that this could produce
a tornado it's got a lot of rotation
already
with all these thunderstorms we're
seeing throughout the region right now
atmospheric changes in wind speed caused
some of them to start rotating
the rotating thunderstorm called a
supercell can suck in warm air and
moisture from the environment
called inflow
as the warm air fuels the storm it
collides with cold air higher up causing
the storm to rotate even faster
and since all those ingredients are in
place that's when the tornado is likely
to drop
there's a lot of motion overhead yeah
this whole area is looking pretty
interesting
how dark the base is getting
wow
it's coming together fast isn't it
[Music]
holy
mike
whoa
yeah that is the photo cloud
we've got a developing funnel cloud
right overhead now
let's wrap it up
there it
[Music]
is go guys
all right let's go
still spinning well
we're gonna head back to the main road
if we can get in front of the
circulation then we can drop our probe
to the ground
tornado warning here's the tornado
warning
it's really intensifying isn't it you
gotta be kidding me look at that
tornado extending down
oh it's beautiful yeah
oh
holy they're going to cross right in
front of us
get out of the way
this is killing me and i've been able to
get to it
damn it
here's the tornado warning
whoa
they're gonna cross right in front of us
let's go it's just a cow you gotta slow
down
get out of the way
damn it
it's drifting out into that field
[Music]
we're gonna miss it
the adrenaline's just pumping through me
right now
it was a small noodle funnel beautiful
tornado the whole process happened right
above us but we just couldn't make the
intercept
boy when it happens does it happen fast
great to at least see a tornado and even
though we weren't able to deploy on that
at least around the board
we got more
that one might stand its ground
oh it's feeding right now
are you serious yes oh no
let's just wait let's wait it out
what a special moment
[Music]
it's a little bit frustrating but i mean
at the same time i'm not gonna be the
guy that's gonna get out of the car and
stop this
okay
all right
there we go they're done
all right well we got a chance
i don't think this thing's producing any
more tornadoes today
[Music]
crystal ball is the earliest third named
storm on record in the atlantic forming
just two days into the hurricane season
crystal ball weakened at the tropical
depression this morning
crystal ball is just another weird part
about what is turning into a very
unusual tornado season
[Music]
chasing day after day is hard but we can
never give up
because that one day you decide the odds
just aren't high enough or you just wake
up exhausted and roll over and go back
to sleep that's the day that's the day
you missed the most amazing picturesque
tornado one that would have been perfect
for us to deploy the probe inside and
collect data
you have to get out of bed morning after
morning and chase everything with any
potential because you never know that
might be your day
we got a tough forecast radar is showing
two major supercell storms right now
they're far enough apart where we
definitely can't chase both but i think
that the threat of tornadoes is probably
about equal between the two yeah
we could always split up i could go
after the southern target you can go
after the northern target yeah
this is the best option with this
pattern we have
increase our odds
i've got the probe on board and if you
get a tornado you can deploy the tice
device
sounds like a plan to me
let's do it all right
good luck good luck to you too be safe
there's the tais device that was
actually in hurricane katrina
that was before gopro so it was a big
camera inside there
we can also get barometric pressure
readings as well
now we just need to get in front of the
tornado
chasing tornadoes it's a long commitment
you have to be on the road for weeks and
weeks and weeks it's a little different
than chasing hurricanes where the
hurricane's coming you get in position
and cover it
in my 20s and 30s i never missed a storm
i was just having so much fun being on
the road
but i can definitely feel the age i woke
up this morning and i could barely stand
up out of bed so at some point you got
to slow down
except greed reed can still chase every
single event
mike and i have very different styles my
mom says i was born with a sword that's
too sharp
i get over excited i like to push the
envelope
i really have no personal life just pure
dedication to storm chasing
but mike has definitely mellowed out a
little bit he has a family and a kid on
the way it's a more laid back methodical
approach to the chase
when we team up together we meet in the
middle we make a really good team
i'm excited about what reed and i can do
with the science
any kind of data we can collect every
little bit helps
[Music]
[Music]
our storm is starting to intensify
this whole storm is behaving like a
vacuum cleaner
the inflow into this thing is so intense
it's starting to suck in more warm air
and moisture
so that's why we're watching closely
underneath for the development of little
dust whirls that'll get stretched up to
the cloud base
as these storms start to encounter the
deeper moisture and they can morph into
a much stronger tornado
let's hook up the probe
our plan is to try to intercept these
and see if we can measure wind speed and
direction and the pressure falls inside
the funnel
[Music]
this touch is down we'll be ready
let's blast and get on this thing
it's already rotating already a
full-blown supercell storm
tornado warning on our storm right now
that dirt
dirt circulation on the ground
that means there's a tornado vortex
above it trying to develop
another big circulation over there
it keeps pumping them out
big time photo right there
see it up there that white thing
spinning violently
that's a tornado trying to connect with
the ground
we're gonna drive up an intercept
the circulation's definitely increasing
in size right now
so my plan now is to get in front of it
and try to move in for intercept we got
the probe ready to go we'll drop the
probe on the ground right in it's bad
[Music]
hold on hold on
we'll catch it
we'll catch it
let's get it
getting lifted back up into the cloud
that was it
this was our road to intercept this damn
thing man
man look at that
look how low that is
all right i gotta pull over
beautiful storm
wow
i gotta get my camera
as a photographer i like to take a step
back and really see the whole storm
structure
you can take in the whole rotation of
the
storm you can see the inflow ingesting
into that supercell that storm fuel
you can see the striations in the
supercell which shows you the curvature
it shows you that that supercell's
rotating like crazy
man look at that thing
reed likes to get right up in there he
likes to have the tornado develop right
on top of his head
if you're right up close there's just a
lot of things that you missed
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
look at the lightning
oh
oh my god
the lightning hit right here
[Music]
i heard the line sizzling so i knew
lightning was coming close and then bam
a hit
gotta catch my breath
right now we're dropping south through
the southern texas panhandle
ingredients are here for tornadoes
including instability
there's a lot of heat and moisture
available to these storms
that's probably our storm right here
you can see an inflow van streaming into
it
and i think that this storm has the
greatest likelihood of becoming a
dominant supercell
get in a little bit better position here
beautiful supercell see everything's
flowing into it
you can see the well-defined rotation on
it
plenty of moisture out here
that warm wind at the back means that
this storm is sucking in inflow
wow
right there look at the middle
that's trying to form a tornado look at
that
[Music]
that is right where it should happen
we got a big time tornado about to touch
down here watch this thing rope out turn
into an elephant truck there it comes we
got a big tornado on the ground
let's get it
all right let's get it
we're gonna cut north here trying to get
right in the path of this tornado
but it is very challenging chase out
here
everything is so hp or high
precipitation that you can't see
anything just driving rain it's like
chasing a tropical storm
oh it's there straight in front of us
look
there it is
big tornado marine
we're gonna try to deploy
we can't get around this can we
oil field traffic only
dammit
can't proceed but we've got a big
tornado close range wrapped right in the
rain here
barely visible because the rain is
wrapping all the way around that
circulation
we're going to intercept this
tornado get in the car now
figure out where to go i think we're
gonna punch into the core of this thing
big time baseball's coming in guys big
hail huge hail
[Applause]
we got a blast back north so we can keep
pace with this thing
but we are getting hit by ice grenades
big time ice grenades right now
oh big time we are getting hammered
we got a blast back north so we can keep
pace with this thing but we are getting
hit by ice grenades
oh that's big big time we are getting
hammered
where is it
i think the tornado just dissipated into
our southeast
dammit
just a moment ago was rotating like
crazy
it's sort of gusting out now i think
the success rate is really low out here
it's not enough just to see a tornado in
the distance
we're trying to record data that no one
else is getting
boy does this storm look good
we need to drop our probe in front of a
shifting twisting moving target and then
try to get out of the way before it gets
us pull over and assess
everybody has a unique natural talent
and i feel like my only skill set is
chasing storms
oh look at that motion
whole circulation's wrapping all the way
around
i see these supercell storms as a living
breathing organism they have a certain
personality
i almost can hear what the supercell is
thinking whether it's about to produce a
tornado
i feel like i have a bit of a sixth
sense
the whole circulation is tilting and
about to come over top of us now
[Music]
here it goes we gotta get in the car now
[Music]
the national weather service has issued
a tornado warning national weather
service doppler radar is tracking a
tornado on the ground
very close there is imminent danger to
life and property
move to an interior room on the lowest
floor of a sturdy building
hey can you hear me
reed's a little bit further north
but we're gonna do our best to get up
there
man
look at all the people hiding from the
hail underneath the overpass
you see that all the time while tornado
chasing but that's actually one of the
worst things you can do because it
blocks the roadways and cars are coming
down and they could slide and crash
right into these cars
it's like driving on ball bearings all
this hail
you got to slow it down as hard as it is
because you want to hurry up and get up
there you don't want to slide up there
[Music]
i'm getting nervous
getting nervous
the tornado is approaching us from the
southeast right now
we've got rain going all the way around
us concealing any view of the tornado
we're starting to get closer to sunset
so not only are these tornadoes wrapped
in rain but they're hitting at night
and that's a dangerous situation
they couldn't come at us out of the rain
keep that in mind
absolute chaos
is a life-threatening situation
so hopefully everybody's in a safe place
it will be interesting to see how the
van which is pretty high profile is
going to hold up
where is it
i see it
tornado
just a mile or two to our southeast
the hail is wrapping all the way around
the circulation
um
to daddy
so we just have to keep moving north as
it drifts slowly back toward the road
trying to get in position to deploy
because you basically got to be inside
the tornado to see it
there it is
whipping around
we've got strong rotation that's
approaching us right now from the
southeast it is coming back toward the
road
we can get this
holy cow
we're right it's fast
all right gotta deploy
here we go
hear the roar of the water
getting close
all right we're recording data
here it comes
we gotta get the car now
got the circulation right on top of us
we're inside a tornado i believe
get hit by debris
oh we're getting rocked
[Music]
we're about to roll the van guys
all right we're recording data
we've got the circulation right on top
of us
we're inside a tornado i believe
gets hit by debris
freaking rocks
we're about to roll the van guys
oh you got to be kidding me with these
wins
complete white out and this thing is
going crazy
look at the right side of the vehicle
[Music]
appears that the circulation has just
passed us off to the east
that was just an incredible win back
there
[Music]
nearly rolled the band
and we've got the probe recording
pressure data all kinds of data back
there
this is one of my best days of my life
hello
hey yeah i can hear you i've been trying
to call you we just intercepted a
tornado that had winds of about 80 to
100 miles an hour
it was wild man
come meet me and i'll fill you in
all right
oh
that's amazing
i'm really jealous i cannot believe he
pulled this one off i was really
concerned about his safety
but this is the kind of thing reed does
i mean reid's crazier
that's what gets him up close to these
tornadoes
the probe is still here
all right
we'll have to check the data logger to
see just how fast those wind speeds got
how low the pressure's dropped
that was intense but we got a data point
that's what it's all about
textbook probe deployment
hey look who it is
that's the herb
the sampling with our tornado probe is a
huge success
getting data about pressure shifts
inside of a tornado is such a rare
occurrence
beautiful probe beacon of science here
we did it
sharing this evidence of the
meteorological community may provide
clues that could help unlock the secrets
of our evolving climate system
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so far this has been one of the most
unusual tornado seasons i've experienced
in my 20 years of storm chasing
we've got an early hurricane season
impacting the weather here in the high
plains tornadoes that are becoming
harder to track and predict and an
overall shift of what is considered
traditional tornado alley
it's also becoming clear that shifting
weather patterns like this are just a
symptom of something bigger
showing that category six storms
monster weather events that are
devastating beyond imagination
are possible in this new climate regime
there was so many storms on the horizon
we'll be there when it happens
[Music]
you